Erica how you doing
I mean look Jim I think we're doing how
um
how is anybody doing this morning when
you look at how this keeps happening and
I you and I have covered too many of
these and I try really hard
um
it's getting harder you think about what
these parents are going through and
they'll never see their kids again news
anchors breaking down reporting on the
mass shooting in Uvalde Texas that left
19 Kids and two adults dead in
elementary school
[Music]
beautiful innocent
second third fourth graders CNN's Erica
Hill couldn't hold back her tears on air
Wednesday as her co-anchor asked how
she's doing following the tragic event
how is anybody doing this morning when
you look at how this keeps happening and
I you and I have covered too many of
these and I try really hard
um
it's getting harder every time we report
on these and you look at the pain in
these parents faces and you think of the
communities that are impacted forever
and the trauma they'll feel the families
the First Responders the teachers every
single person who works in that school
the other children
who survived similar sentiments were
shared by Fox News host Ainsley Earhart
who choked up speaking about The
Grieving families and you think about
what these parents are going through and
they'll never see their kids again
you know and even if they have three
kids it doesn't replace the one that
they lost but what about the mom who has
one child and she will never be a
grandmother because this man went into
these schools and did this hill and
Earhart are just two of the many on-air
personalities who've shared emotional
reactions to the tragedy like the ladies
of the view these are live
they're little children's lives right
and I think there's something about that
aspect that so shocks the conscience
Kelly Ripa and Ryan Seacrest I can tell
you personally
um the toll that this takes on these
families are forever
the Mark has been left forever they'll
never this is unrecoverable and late
night Stars James Corden and Stephen
Colbert who host shows that usually
start with laughter instead they shared
somber messages in their opening
monologues Stephen asking for prayers
and change while we can add our prayers
for the dead there is nothing
they can never be said they can approach
the immeasurable grief of those families
but while we're at it let's pray this
time our leaders show a modicum of
courage in trying to prevent this from
ever happening again and James a dad to
three kids tries to comprehend how The
Grieving parents are feeling
it's unfathomable
[Music]
as a father I can't imagine the horror
of that phone call
when I drop my kids off at school this
morning and kiss them goodbye it doesn't
cross your mind that that could ever be
the last goodbye
and the thought of that phone call
[Music]
that your child is the victim in a mass
shooting is beyond comprehension as a
human being